-Could we just run down
everything that's
happened to you since
you were last on our show?
-Mm-hmm.
-You won an Oscar for
"12 Years a Slave."
-Not bad.
-Yeah, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You were in a couple of
small films --
"Star Wars" and "Black Panther."
You got a Tony nomination...
-Mm-hmm!
-...for your -- Yeah.
And then probably
most important --
your name is now
a Beyoncé lyric.
-I mean, yeah.
-I mean, come on. That's --
-Yeah, that's it.
-How fun is that?
"Brown Skin Girl" -- she says,
"She needs an Oscar
for that pretty dark skin.
Pretty like Lupita when the
cameras close in."
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that!
Now, how do you hear about that?
Does Beyoncé call you and give
you a heads-up that she --
-No! Queen Bee does not tell
anyone anything.
No, I was in London
and I was doing a press junket
for a documentary I did called
"Warrior Women."
And the first journalist
is just interviewing me,
and she says, "How do you feel
now that you're
a Beyoncé lyric?"
And I was like,
"What are you talking about?"
And she was like, "Really?
It dropped this morning.
You don't know?"
And I was like,
"No, I don't know.
What are you talking about?"
"Oh, my God!
Am I the first person
to tell you?"
And I was like, "Yes, you are."
-"You're an absolute
lyric right now.
Yeah, it's madness."
-She was so chuffed.
-Yeah. But you're also --
I found out,
you're a Jay-Z lyric, as well.
-I am, yes!
-What's going on with the...
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're obsessed.
What's going on with
the Carters?
-I don't know.
I love the Carters,
and they seem to love me.
I'm not mad.
-Do you like anyone better?
Which song do you like --
-Oh, no, I couldn't do that.
I couldn't choose
between the two, no.
-I've heard you rap before.
You rap,
but what do you rap under?
A different name, right?
-Yes.
-Well, who are you?
-Troublemaker.
-Ah! That's what
I'm talking about.
Yeah, Troublemaker.
Could you give us
a little sample of a rap?
-I mean...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
-Well, the thing -- Okay,
the thing about Troublemaker --
first of all, I was baptized
Troublemaker by Common,
so I feel like it's legit.
-Wow.
-And it's something I do
in a car.
I need a car.
But, okay, if I had a mic,
like, a mic --
Oh, and every respectable -- Oh!
-We always have --
We have so many microphones.
Whichever one you want to use.
-Yeah, a respectable emcee
has that.
But then, also, one of
the things I have to have
as Troublemaker is shades, so --
Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just give -- Just a taste.
Just a taste.
-Oh, my goodness.
Okay, only if The Roots
will join me!
♪♪
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Oh!
That's a dope beat. Okay.
Hold up.
♪ Troublemaker
in the building, hey ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I feel some bars coming ♪
♪ Bars coming ♪
♪ Oh-oh ♪
♪ Much love to the Carters,
Hova and Beyoncé ♪
♪ They always big me up
in a big way ♪
♪ I'm a brown-skin girl,
so that means a lot ♪
♪ Hov said we made it,
got an Oscar for my props ♪
♪ Much love to Jimmy and
The Roots 'cause they hot ♪
♪ Wrote a book about self-love,
"Sulwe" is 'bout to drop ♪
♪ October 15th, on time,
tick-tock ♪
♪ Better go to commercial or
these bars won't stop ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yes! Wow!
Hey! You can do it. Yeah!
That was amazing! Troublemaker!
Oh, I love it!
Dude, come on.
Song of the summer.
Let's see more Troublemaker.
I love it, pal.
Thank you for doing that.
-I'm a one-hit wonder.
-No, I loved that.
-Thank you.
-Did you used to do that --
Like, do you do
that on set and, like --
I mean, do you perform
all the time?
-I'm a fraud.
-You are a fraud.
-I mean, I feel like
in my past li--
I am supposed to be a rapper,
but I'm not.
-You're not.
-So I just -- I do it for fun.
I like to play a rapper, but
I'm really not one.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
I thought that was fantastic.